maybe they think he sees me oh [ __ ] I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
ah doors everywhere uh to the place
where the lever was I'm floating around
cuz I'm a dead pig mm-hmm
I'm a snake I'm a snake you thought I
was pig I thought I was bait no I'm
sneak look almost like I think it was in
here yeah I'm a snake I'm excited ye ye
snakes
whoa did you see that backflip holy [ __ ]
that was I'm a genius I'm a genius
uh oh
[ __ ] why did I do this whether I do this
[ __ ] he's gonna come in here
don't look at so many doors and walls oh
I don't want to seize my moves
let's go okay okay I'm sorry I'm sorry
about everything
I didn't mean to touch your ass oh [ __ ]
he's talking through the barrels I knew
it I [ __ ] knew it
the barrels yeah yeah I know I need you
Stefano where are you Stefano get the
way out down off the light with a eyes
coming at you
okay you're safe now you know I was hug
me I don't wanna get I don't own a right
I need Stefano seriously though where's
that it's not Savannah wait listen
hello lady
what have you been I've looked
everywhere for you what are you doing on
top of a shelf I don't know where'd he
go oh [ __ ] step on up oh there is he's
in a really bad spot
it's the funnel okay carefully it's a
carefully PD that monster is is blind
you can see you just don't make a noise
okay
okay so funny I'll try ah bucks if I
dolly right away arrives that's sorry
Stefania like oh [ __ ] I get the feeling
he sees me
no no no it's cold he doesn't see you
it's a problem is me
yeah ask me what it feels like seven a
disguise so Vendela telling Kurt Russell
homie to say real like I'll be making
good on my promises honesty is pop it
inside of it is missing but I realized I
can be better than I was later on my
feet
cooking up the song when we fire up